voyez donc appartenir à une aristocratie
des lecteurs oui bien sûr on va bien sûr
je sais pas si j appartiens
le supersonique il faut une aristocratie
agriculteurs et pensez vous du livre de
poche beaucoup de mal pourquoi parce que
ça fait lire un tas de missions qui
n'avait pas de sens de dire finalement
qui n'avait jamais ressenti le besoin de
lire on les a amenés là on leur a vendu
10 un vieux loup de où l'avion flare et
d'un seul coup ils se sont retrouvés
avec sartre dans les mains ce qui leur a
donné une espèce de prédation
intellectuelle qui n'avaient pas dire
que les gens avant les gens étaient un
bleu devant finalement la littérature
alors que maintenant se permet de la
prendre de haut
jantes acquis le droit de mépris
maintenant ce qu'ils n'avaient pas avant